Nowadays, when you see a contest,...
...it's gonna usually be a street contest or a park contest.
A park contest is a mixture of transition and like flowy, more flowy style...
...and street style is gonna be handrails, stairs, ledges.
In park, you're going to really want to look out for speed and patterns.
People are going to be going.
They're going to be doing really long grinds, they're going to be going really high,...
And they're going to be going what kind of pattern they choose...
...it's the way the judge is going to score.
And for street, what you're really going to want to look out for...
...and this can be pretty obvious, is the big section.
The big section is the part of the park right in the middle...
...which has the biggest handrails and you know, it's the highest risk.
And everyone looks different on a skateboard.
Everyone has a different style and just even going to the Olympics...
...and how just creative it is and how everyone looks different on a skateboard,...
...I think that's really cool and it's more of an art form than a competitive sport.